est-ce qu'il est un sans prévenir et du
coup ben j'ai perdu j'ai perdu les
caméras j'ai perdu Kevin pendant un
petit moment
je la magie direct la magie qui est
perdu et du coup comme j'ai pas de
caméra et ben je vous ai mis je vous ai
mis la belle
la belle
image avec les scores et vous voyez que
du coup le petit spoil de Ding qui a
battu a priori qui a battu gokash on va
si c'est du coup à la fin de la partie
alors pendant ce temps là je vais
essayer de récupérer les caméras si vous
voulez bien
on va voir alors stuff oui on nous
annonce une
combinaison de folie comme ils ont de
folie de covidge avec tout reprend 4
c'est ce qu'on imaginait un scooter
prend un cadre qui pourrait venir
affaiblir toutes les cases blanches
maintenant il faut qu'on voit vraiment
ce que ça a donné et oui pas de métal la
victoire du roi tout nu évidemment parce
que
au-delà de ça le roi G1 mais il n'était
pas serein et on a hâte de voir quand
même le final et la partie de Digne et
vraiment monstrueuse en fait
alors là les idées que j'ai trois elles
peuvent faire mal
et bien sûr tout reprend E4 c'est le
coup qu'on attendait en fin de
parce que alors tout reprend le cadre ça
peut être juste vous baisser cette dame
c'est 6 avec les cases blanches et sur
dame prend le 4 c'est ça qu'il faut
vérifier est-ce que on va avoir des
thèmes alors avec avec vous prenez F2
comment on fait pour finir tous les
trois sans doute et 3 il a peut-être
joué stuff ça serait peut-être la
combinaison
avec les deux pièces
pris en brochette là sur le terme
blanches
qui va gagner la dame
hyper jolie
c'est le classique avec le roi Gien qui
est plus tout nu en fait pas de métal
parce que nous on avait plus de casse
blanche
ah oui ça a été la partie tu reprends
dans 3
j'aurais bien aimé voir la conclusion
tout reprend tout reprend il y avait
peut-être aussi il faut des trois en
fait
des trois tout le temps
et là vous cache a dû signer
mais la partie de Digne franchement avec
la position finale sauf on se régale
totalement quoi c'est monstrueux
[Musique]
il y a eu de Monsieur
normalement
on trouve c'est parce que l'indication
qui est que le joueur joue pour prendre
4 bah ça nous donne vraiment trop quoi
normalement je vais regarder si un
joueur sacrifie du matériel c'est qu'il
a vu une combine
donc le G3 final fait qu'on peut on peut
jouer ta variante tout et être serein
parce que le petit G3 il va provoquer
l'abandon
alors là
voilà ça va être ça va être perdu
incroyable quelle démonstration de
Rennes
la digne quand vraiment il est en forme
il peut tellement fort franchement c'est
un joueur qui m'a toujours impressionné
on voit que la lambda qui a fait nul
d'ailleurs contre irigazi
ça a fait nul tu t'es attendu
et répétition
superbe donc
c'est assez marrant parce qu'on a on n'a
pas été voir Wesley Jordan van Forest en
fait
personne nous l'a demandé non
rapidement
et découvrir ce qu'ils font ah peut-être
à porte va tenir ça nul c'est pas loin
en tout cas c'est final de tour il y a
un avantage il y a deux mois ça c'est ce
qu'il va falloir
il faut échanger h contre g ça c'est sûr
ça peut être facile là finalement non
c'est pas facile
pas facile à suivre
laisse-moi découvrir du coup ouais bien
sûr bien sûr la partie qu'on a pas
encore regardé depuis le début c'est
vrai qu'on a un peu oublié cette partie
là
et nous demander un les parties que vous
voulez voir n'hésitez pas en tout cas
et du coup ici
les Noirs ont un peu d'avance et un roi
punaise domine très clairement mais il y
a les fous de couleur opposés sauf
qu'ils pourraient qui pourrait venir
amener un résultat
un peu plat que les pièces blanches sont
très très actives
oui forte chance de nul quand même grâce
au
foot couleur opposé
même si des fois pour manger 4 tout à
fait bien vu
mais quand je vois
les deux joueurs ont trois minutes à la
pendule enfin quatre contre trois mais
là ils sont 40e donc ils vont avoir
droit un rajout de temps à 50 minutes
supplémentaires
donc mais bon on pense quand même que ça
va faire nul sans trop trop de problèmes
en pleinement cette partie
donc Google je fais ça c'est
officiellement terminé quasiment je
pense il y a eu la vente qu'on a donné
et il lui prend ses 5 mais là du coup il
va il va manger un F2 et on va devenir
grand à Rennes partie extraordinaire un
peu se lancer dans le dans le tournoi
décisif le seul peut-être de la ronde
d'ailleurs en plus donc exactement
bien dit mais celle-là est monstrueuse
franchement c'est l'école de de la
couleur quoi du de la paire de fou
H3
précis qui empêche le roi de venir ici
se cacher et après prise je ferai d'âme
et là du coup ça va être un bonbon parce
que là il y a deux pièces de plus il y a
plus de coup
et ce qui est marrant c'est que ce
retour c'est deux tu peux même faire
[ __ ] en F2 ah oui c'est Boston
[Rires]
et là j'ai le j'ai vu le point nommé moi
j'avais toujours pas vu tu sais
mais non bon on arrive à 5h de Live donc
voilà
ça garait quand même on a une pièce
d'avance
ok bon ça va être la pause qu'on fait ça
se trouve non
on se revoit d'ici ben 5 minutes même
pas pour le moment de la ronde et voir
comment les parties de rapport et vente
forest se termine toujours pareil et
puis pendant la pause vous aurez les
petites pubs on vous met un petit saut
vers nos chaînes respectives comme ça
vous avez tout on a déjà parlé on vous
donne on redonne tout et comme ça vous
êtes vous êtes peinard vous avez des
choses à faire pendant la pause
voir nos stream voir tout ça je vous
envoie
vers Kevin aussi
et puis et puis je vous dis à tout de
suite allez à tout de suite tout le
monde je vous mets le petit cadeau si ça
vous intéresse pour la plateforme de
cours et comme ça on se retrouve tout de
suite à tout de suite
attends attends attends parce que du
coup comme mon comme mon Obs et la
crèche il y a quelques secondes et ben
il faut que je remette
j'ai mon setup qui a sauté
c'est la caméra j'avais fait des caméras
là
là on est hors direct à un souffle c'est
ça non non non
mais j'ai le setup qui a sauté en fait
on est là on est là donc
oui bien sûr
connecté en fait ce qui se passe et tout
ben voilà oppose doit mettre les petites
pubs
cheesecom tata style et compagnie dans
ces conditions bah effectivement comme
son logiciel de stream à sauter et ben
il doit tout reconfigurer
qui est pas hyper plaisant donc je peux
je peux continuer à vous commenter un
petit peu cette petite finale de tour
quasiment
incroyable en tout cas Richard rapporte
il est en train d'essayer de promouvoir
son pion d pour essayer de trouver un
contre-pouvoir dans cette position et je
suis en train de regarder roi B5 il y a
tout ces cinq échecs alors où il va
mettre son roi Richard rapport il est
très ennuyé dans cette situation
sur mon Décathlon
il va falloir tenir ce pion par défaut
on le met en D4 sur la même colonne que
le pion ce qui est pas l'idéal que ça
laissera toujours tourner un son
adversaire il va falloir y aller on a
pas le choix défaut et vous aurez la
réponse juste après la pub allez à tout
de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin pour
ce dénouement de rondins du tata style
donc la partie qui n'ont pas trop trop
avancé en notre absence
on a une finale de tour qui va être
instructif France et une finale de foot
couleur opposé qui va être quand même
moins rigolote je pense mais bon c'est
que c'est que mon avis pour le moment
ouais alors déjà attends
je me suis trompé d'onglet yes donc oui
cette tour bah écoute deux tours il y a
un pion d'avance je peux perdre celui là
échanger ici et a priori Kevin je vois
pas trop trop dans quel monde on peut la
perdre avec
avec les blancs en fait peut-être que si
peut-être que non
comment tu la
pensée
j'ai des thèmes voilà c'est exactement
sur l'accroche français
doute c'est quand même nul mais il faut
essayer de ramener le roi déjà
ça c'est sûr
le jour où tu vas manger ce plan là je
prendrai celui-là j'aurais peut-être le
temps de m'activer dans un petit peu mon
rat il y a quand même des
coupes en fait ça va être ça peut être
autant pour presse ce genre de finale
donc B4 en tout cas le concept c'est
exactement ça de pas donner trop de
valeur au pion des en tout cas là les
blancs menacées
il était important de faire quelque
chose de toute façon
de conserver des chances pratiques donc
ça c'est une des positions tu sais tout
à l'heure on avait regardé le jeune
michera qui était censé gagner très vite
et je vois que son résultat n'est pas
encore figé
effectivement
est-ce que tu peux nous dire un petit
peu stouf si il y a une évolution ou non
il a gagné ça fait un moment en fait
le sens
[Musique]
ici on avait dit que sur D4 il y a plein
de coupe pour essayer de
4 donc il y a eu d'un point B3 et après
tours je crois après tu vois
un stage là on va dire
n'importe qui aurait joué déjà toutes
ces sept par exemple tu vois qu'il y a
l'air fort
les finales que le reste voilà une carte
technique
et juste là il échange parce qu'il voit
qu'il va gagner ce pion il veut pas
perdre celui-là donc il va échanger la
tour pour défendre l'option B4
j'ai buggé ça faisait longtemps après
vous pensez vite avec vous c'est ici cet
enfant
en tout cas je vous rappelle qu'il est
un peu de 13 ans
il n'a que 13 ans oui c'est le plus
jeune grand maître de tous les temps
quand même avec les Blancs donc ça veut
dire quelque chose
le plus grand espoir actuellement au
monde après on va voir des fois ça
change c'est pas parce qu'on a un grand
grand espoir qu'on devient champion du
monde non
faut confirmer donc
il y a pas de il y a pas de il y a pas
de français donc furosa est toujours
fâché avec l'organisation et
mvl bon c'est pas s'il a été invité ou
si tu n'as pas voulu y aller les deux
sont possibles mais malheureusement on
n'a pas de français c'est dommage
mais on a quand même pas mal de fin on a
quand même un beau plateau on a bon on a
c'est un petit peu comment dire comment
en début de stream vraiment l'expérience
contre la Genèse parce qu'on a on a les
caractères les saules les dignes les
Caravana les aronyanes enfin voilà
et en fait on a aussi des jeunes qui
sont les jeunes qui vont en flèche comme
on a Kemer on a par exemple on a
irriguez on a choisi
on a McDo slow il y a vraiment quasiment
tout ça c'est vraiment une bataille de
intergénérationnel
de voir ça devant les jeunes qui se
mêlent un petit peu à la bataille avec
les grands donc pour l'instant il y a eu
dans le tournoi on va dire master dans
le tournoi a une seule victoire pour
l'instant signé dingly Rennes contre
Google partie incroyable les rédacteur
d'une partie
monstrueuse juste génial et
ensuite de belles parties quand même ça
va être guéri il a il a fait un bon taf
contre Kawana la première partie noire
très très intéressante
il a poussé mais il a pas été forcément
très précis dans la réalisation et au
final ben écoute c'est pas moi c'est
grand chose et Prague c'était une partie
très très théorique jusqu'à très loin et
les deux joueurs ont été très précis
parce que ça aurait pu se retourner pour
un sens ou dans l'autre et donc le
désordre qui était bons amis et donc
deux parties en jeu on a rapport contre
on a vu il y a quelques instants et on a
cette partie là où on a vente forest
avec le blanc contre so Weasley donc un
peu plus pour ça mais il y a plus en 93
et
bon il y a encore abassé mais bon on
imagine que le pion h vont un jour
peut-être s'échanger et que on ira
manger les curs là-bas on parlera
celui-là moi je pense que c'est nul
assez clair
cette partie là ça va normalement faire
nul après faut bien faire le taf parce
que ça peut aller vite de de déconner
une position comme ça donc il va être
sérieux genre de Van forest on peut dire
oui qui m'a pas l'air
pour contrôler c'est c'est cohérent pour
contrôler la prise en H2 et pouvoir
jouer des G4 en compte dangereux tu peux
peut-être faire G5 G6 G7 et dames que je
peux pousser rapidement c'est pas simple
alors que du coup cavaler prend B2 je
peux aussi faire cavaler prendre 4 ou
prendre un H2 de prendre mon petit pion
monter mon roi et essayer d'échanger les
pions et c'est nul quoi mais Rick foue
F4 ça a l'air de défendre à H2 et je me
dis qu'après je vais manger le Pione 4
peut-être de manière plus confortable et
après essayer d'aller manger des pions à
la
donc
voilà je sais pas du tout aussi
salut à toi salut à tous ceux qui
arrivent sur le stream
donc n'hésitez pas à les voir des
parties il en reste plus beaucoup on a
rapport Abdou on a besoin de Foresto et
si vous avez des questions ou quoi que
ce soit surtout n'hésitez pas on
essaiera de vous répondre
le plus rapidement possible
là les finales sont un petit peu plus
tranquilles c'est peut-être la finale de
Tours qui est la plus la plus
intéressante des deux et certaines nous
donner l'occasion d'aller voir un peu ce
qui s'est passé dans le challenger je
sais pas ce que tu en penses le temps
que ça se déconse un peu on peut aller
voir le challenge effectivement
que vous voyez on a deux finales qui
sont un peu terne donc ils vont évoluer
mais les joueurs ont beaucoup beaucoup
de temps surtout
1h30
2h de cadence est-ce que ça marche
oui ça marche
donc là c'est la fameuse partie 2
c'était le plus faible et l'eau mise à
part Eline Robert
qui va donc être en difficulté
du coup ça va quand même
je pense pour la petite ligne Robert qui
est la seule chose moins de 2400 et dans
ce tournoi ça veut dire quelque chose
tellement c'est fort
[Musique]
pour tabataveil les pions qui sont très
éloignés et qui peut du coup peut-être
permettre à tabatabeille avec les blancs
de venir manger 6
mais ça a l'air quand même beaucoup de
travail à faire pour les blancs avec le
cavalier Vienne tac tac manger ici plus
tard qui vient de manger ici
éviter tous les sacrifices de fou et
pendant ce temps-là manger lui manger
lui revenir
je sais pas trop ce que ça va
que ça va donner
en tout cas vous voyez un ça se décanté
sur pas mal d'échiquier alors qu'il
reste beaucoup de temps à tous les
joueurs et maintenant il faut faire
parler à technique en tout cas dans
cette position
il y a des chances que
que ça soit nul
donc
c'est un joueur de l'équipe olympique
[Musique]
Ouzbékistan qui a du coup gagné la
médaille d'or lors des dernières
Olympiades donc un joueur très jeune à
surveiller aussi le prêt
nul avec les noirs
on a
Erwin Lamy contre toupie
cette compétition c'est le jour le plus
long mais tous les jours au niveau de la
cadence et manutention c'est vrai que tu
nous as posé cette question tout à
l'heure on l'a laissé filer je me
demandais pourquoi est-ce que les
joueurs notent les coups à l'écrit
sachant que tout est enregistré filmé
surveillé en fait c'est une règle du jeu
d'échec parce que effectivement
en compétition autre les joueurs ne sont
pas toujours filmés avec échiquier des
GT etc donc la règle de base de la feed
compte pour toutes les parties on peut
pas changer les règles
même si les matchs de foot voilà sont
filmés etc les règles sont les mêmes
pour les pro et les amateurs donc voilà
c'est ça ne change pas au foot ça ne
change pas aux échecs en tout cas c'est
une obligation on va dire des règles
voilà donc c'est vrai qu'on quality il y
aura aussi les cames tout ça mais c'est
une règle donc on est obligé de
respecter les règles donc tu dois noter
du monde ils sont que deux il y a 10000
caméras 10000 arbitres ils sont deux
mais une note quand même le parti c'est
juste les règles
donc l'ami en grande grande grande
difficulté puisqu'il a une qualité de
moins sans compensation je crois qu'il
arrive et qu'on le fou bouge il peut y
avoir des dames qui peuvent rentrer sur
casse blanche donc là il y a le cavalier
qui descend mais on peut s'imaginer même
un petit fou de 4
H3 oula sweat full G4
position à un travail du joueur
brésilien devrait
lui permettre d'assurer le gain
mais un résultat donc décisif
dans cette partie
de dernière minute
ivitch qui a remplacé le numéro 1 du
tournoi au pied levé
qui
remplaceions de plus pour un produit le
Mase avec les Noirs mais il y a au moins
B2 qui tombe sur échec suivi de F3
en fait ça dépend c'est du coup au blanc
de joint coup
il y a une faiblesse là
alors est-ce qu'on a foussé trois non
fousser 5 non on n'a pas moyen en fait
de gérer la problématique sur B2
parce que
et
fourchette
je redescends à tour avec mon cavalier
pour sauver B2 et si je chauffe pas B2
ben je vais encore
je vais laisser des plumes et c'est fou
de couleur opposé là encore je trouve
donc beaucoup de jeux pour le joueur
noir et
une masse il a peut-être raté le gars
avant parce qu'il a tellement de pions
de plus que il avait peut-être position
qui était meilleur tout à l'heure je ne
sais pas complètement gagnant
il a dû bien bugger il a commencé à
lâcher des sa santé tu vois que les
trois pions de plus se soufflent il a
voulu faire mat
voyez même à 2600 ça peut devenir
difficile il s'est complètement troué
parce que le cavalier divine chez une
tactique a permis de sortir ce cavalier
du bois sauf surtout quand j'ai tout
prend échec et du coup le Caval qui
ressemble et qui fait très mal
parti en fait
j'ai quatre qui s'ouvre la partie
quel est son vrai
qui a battu petshock PetShop qui est
maintenant bah je crois le numéro ah non
qui est pas le numéro 1 qui est le
numéro 2 après tabac tabac en termes
d'Elo
pour t'expliquer on fait un petit tour
par le challengeur parce que on a
vraiment parlé pendant tout le stream
qui est de voilà de plusieurs de
plusieurs heures on est là depuis 14h à
peu près un tout petit peu avant
on a parlé voilà du tournoi principal
avec Magnus Carlsen kerwana harognan
bref les les vieux routards et on a
aussi toute la jeune génération avec
Erika ici avec Google
et maintenant on a décidé d'aller voir
le challenger un petit peu pour cette
fin de stream et on repart on passe en
revue
tous les autres joueurs à peu près 2600
hello de moyenne des jeunes et des
joueurs très expérimentés qui voudraient
se qualifier au tournoi à l'an prochain
ouais donc
ah oui le petit H4 parce que c'était la
vente avec fubé 5 cavaliers d'accord
oui parce que ça fait penser à une
italienne cette position mais avec le
caillou en G6 et on joue H4
[Musique]
dans ces positions ils ont fait plaisir
rigolo les noirs sont assez en retard
cette partie
[Musique]
là on va assez vite on n'hésite pas de
tout à fait
en tout cas il a ramené du monde à la
fête les ramené les pièces
et je fais le petit moulinet bien sûr le
moulinet regardez bien
on va pas
[Musique]
par contre le moulinet
en fait je viens de me dire un truc
est-ce que ton moulin est moulinet
mouline vraiment en début parce qu'il y
a tout F6 et ça donne la case fuite au
roi
quand tu vas proposer le moulinet je me
suis dit oui au pire on récupère la dame
mais en fait
au tout début donc OK
je vais quand même donner
au début tu m'as fait tout rêve 7 donc
OK
dès que je peux je donne pour me barrer
[Musique]
qu'il en fera pas des milliers c'est
rare de faire match sur l'échiquier pour
les joueurs à plus de 2600 ça arrive
quasiment jamais après souvent pour
certains se faire laisser maths comme ça
c'est aussi une une forme de respect des
fois on peut le voir comme un comme un
irresp par rapport à pas mal de joueurs
mais souvent cette forme de respect dans
le sens tu as fait une super partie et
va jusqu'au bout quoi tu vois ce que
veut dire
ça je l'ai vu plein de fois et du coup
je pense
et bien sûr comme toi
[Musique]
mais c'est un peu des fois quand on a
une dame d'avance pas et qui continue ça
c'est un pays respect à haut niveau par
contre quand tu quand tu joues une
partie comme celle que j'aime faire
avoir d'Inde c'est un peu je pense une
marque respect tu vois de d'aller
jusqu'au maths pour tu vois pour finir
la partie tu vois
je le vois comme ça et pas le voir comme
un non respect wal le mec il est pas
sportif
du Shanghai il y en a quelques-unes qui
sont jolies
partie intéressante dans le principal
pas trop c'est des finales ouais on va
aller voir un petit peu de termes il
reste une finale de tour quand même
on va aller voir cette partie quand même
donc la sœur tu nous disait de Prague la
seule qui a les qui est le noir ici
ils sont inspirés
[Musique]
qui est plus simple
des deux peut-être fou c'est 5
ok donc
ça a l'air très très bien pour les
blancs quand même
les noirs sont quand même vachement
affaiblis
le G5 on y revient un petit peu
dommage d'avoir très très bien joué avec
les Blancs
aussi magnifique franchement il joue
comme un dieu là avec avec les blancs
avec des idées de maths aussi par là de
partout ce qu'il a mis c'est ouf la
partie est somptueuse
et au final ça fait nul
à répétition
ok bon grosse partie des deux mais c'est
vrai que le G5 est très ambitieux des
Noirs qui
a été pas mal de réussite quand même
parce que oui elle aurait pu très vite
pour la partie elle est elle dans le
challenger on vient de voir deux parties
extraordinaires pour le niveau de
d'intensité
des grosses grosses attaques
hyper chaud ok est-ce qu'on repart dans
le temps principal allez on va aller
voir les finales allez on va voir ce que
Richard rapporte va réussir à tenir
parce qu'il a fait le choix Richard
rapport de ne pas prendre en
B4 pour avoir
du jeu avec champion des
jeux peut-être
[Musique]
tourbé 8 après il y aurait tour des
trois
ça c'est les positions qui sont
extrêmement dures là c'est beaucoup de
calcul et de décision
en tout cas vous voyez que les deux
joueurs regardent leur tour active et le
roi actif ça c'est vraiment une des clés
et maintenant faut valoriser les pions
forts c'est ce que les pions BD nous
montre
les B3 ça a l'air d'être le coup
logique dans la position
[Musique]
que j'ai B2 et B1 donc à 5 ça pose une
question réelle très intéressant
ouais mais ça veut dire que je ne peux
plus bouger
[Musique]
pour ceux qui est qui se demandent un
petit peu qui ne connaissent pas les
joueurs qui jouaient tout à l'heure une
finale foot couleur opposé avec un
cavalier chacun est-ce que ça évolue un
petit peu stouf je pense qu'on va se
concentrer bientôt sur la finale de
tours on va aller voir
il a joué le cavaler prend un 4
au F4 et cavaler C3 je pense qu'il va
vite aller essayer d'aller manger des
mois mais il va secouer il y a un pion
son roi est actif tu vois que le
cavalier noir ne bouge plus bizarre on
peut pas faire caca en plus donc le
cahier est enfermé d'un point de vue
stratégique stuff
j'ai change et nul oui d'accord mais tu
as pas le choix si je peux en fait
ça c'est tout à fait vrai ou pas
est-ce que j'ai est-ce que j'ai un roi
projet 3 sur ton coup souffle ah ok bon
tu es vicieux toi effectivement
stratégiquement autrement tu peux
attendre maintenant on fait un presque
que le mec joue rien quoi
si on fait A3 pour me chercher
[Musique]
un cavalier donc ça va être dur un fou
B8 je vais faire
non mais c'est nul celle-là elle est
nulle
en plus je pense faire nul parce que tu
vas réussir à toucher ça va tu vas
réussir à changer les pions et tu peux
même te dire que tu sais que tu as la
finale avec le pion a pleinement donc tu
peux même des fois
échanger les pièces pour échanger lui
contre lui et après je sais pas échanger
les cavaliers mettre ton four sur B6
sympa ce joueur de Forest
il est très sympa
au top et il est très très cool très
serein je prends pas la tête et ça
fonctionne
donc bah finalement pour pour le
suspense qu'on peut aller du côté de la
partie effectivement de Richard rapporte
contrat d'où ça torov c'est la seule
partie qui est encore un certain il y a
eu B3 d'ailleurs B3 Tour Eiffel
et comment est-ce qu'on compte s'il est
mieux
ah oui si je vais à 4
et tout remettre cache je pense
j'ai pas envie d'aller en F3
pas tout de suite du moins
oui même en fait je peux faire 4
ouais c'est ça
rapporte là
on va contrôler
en fait un peu de données on fait bien
c'est complètement trompé je crois non
comment ça va
mais de toute façon bon c'est la partie
ah il s'est trompé deux
[Musique]
c'était obligé mais bon roi des trois il
s'est trompé Richard rapporte c'est
trompé et la partie
[Musique]
réfléchit il essaie de trouver des
solutions mais
je me suis dit ça va être intéressant de
voir comment Richard apporte fait pour
tenir la pose bah finalement on l'a on
l'a pas trop vu
il s'est pas rendu compte encore tu vois
le truc enfin c'est pas si il se rend
compte plus vite que nous mais ils ont
envie ces mecs là ils sont forts aussi
parce que même dans les positions
difficiles ils arrivent à trouver les
ressources bon là effectivement il y en
a plus trop
bah ouais
va partir
partie brillante quand même parce que
au-delà de la finale avant il a réussi à
montrer des choses
des choses très importantes et Richard
rapporte il était pas loin quand même de
tirer ça nul en ayant une partie de
souffrance et je vois en beaucoup de
ressources mais prendre un point c'est
normal
l'ouverture un peu ratée quand même de
Richard rapport il a pas obtenu grand
chose il a mal vendu la Viennoise
heureusement que je vous ai livré des
petites pépites pour pour éviter ça pour
éviter le fiasco de la Viennoise dama F3
non non on va pas faire confiance à
Richard du coup comme on a dit
Néandertal
et Abdou je pense qu'il réfléchit
pourquoi parce que il doit pas en
revenir il devait trouver ça assez
compliqué et
là ça s'est complètement
français honnêtement qu'on avait pour
pour longtemps avec cette finale sous
fin
[Musique]
et tu fais ça
ça
je pense que ça va être pareil pour pour
ça et son compère
qui vont faire nul je pense d'ici
quelques minutes
un petit quart d'heure je vous le dis
qui quart d'heure ou est-ce les sauve à
va tourner voilà comment je vois les
choses touffe
j'arrive voilà
de faire ça ouais parce que maintenant
avec mon cavalier je peux lutter contre
les deux petits pions tu peux faire caca
tu es obligé de le regarder au niveau du
calcul mais voilà
mais ils ont mis les rois au centre et
ça fait genre du coup il aurait sûrement
joué 6 et il m'a attaquer les pions et
ça aurait été nul très très vite donc du
coup la seule partie qui nous reste
c'est la partie de Richard Harper du
coup contre
VA Adam mais en fait il va se le faire
claquer
sa petite dame va se faire claquer par
la tour adverse donc ce qu'il faut
calculer encore c'est qu'à la fin quand
même parce que la tombe blanche
va venir là mais pendant ce temps là
Laura va venir là et le pion avancera
donc en fait
si par exemple je fais un petit dessin
ça fera genre d'ailleurs je peux même
pas j'ai pas le temps
ah j'ai chacun à cette position
oui mais en fait j'ai pas le temps
de faire ça
je te laisse un tempo même un tempo
[Rires]
un bon gros un bon gros tempo s'il te
plaît
je vais aller manger celui-là et le roi
blanc va être un petit peu trop loin à
un temps prévu vous voyez j'ai 4 G4
le chemin du Pione
[Musique]
on avait donné du tempo pour arriver là
alors que on en est loin quand même en
réalité oui parce que parce que voilà
c'est terminé en fait c'est terminé
exactement politique pas ouais on a un
petit peu halluciné en fin de en fin de
variante mais non franchement
aujourd'hui il y a eu des belles parties
donc là on a terminé avec les parties
d'aujourd'hui je vais vous afficher du
coup les résultats de la journée pour
qu'on puisse faire un petit un petit
débrief voir ce qu'il s'est passé c'est
pas encore totalement à jour mais je
vais quand même vous le vous le montrer
non c'est même pas du tout à jour il y a
aucun résultat
peut-être sur le petit tableau qui est
que sur une des scènes
en dessous mettre un souffle je vais
vous mettre le score
non non
[Musique]
ça c'est pas moi qui le touche non mais
terrible
maintenant tu as vu ça va vite hein
incroyable en fait si tu veux tout ce
qui est résultat
des trucs bon je peux vous les montrer
mais apparemment tout ce qui est posé en
fait c'est des trucs qui sont faits par
télescom et moi malheureusement je
n'écoute pas c'est pas moi qui est qui
est mis tout ça en place donc du coup
alors je peux vous montrer si vous
voulez ça va être plus simple je vais
vous montrer le le
le master ici voilà et les challengers
donc là vous voyez les joueurs qui ont
qui ont un point qu'on a ding qui a qui
a battu du coup cache hauteur d'une
superbe partie je pense clairement la
partie de la journée c'est magnifique de
la ronde ouais on a eu App Store qui a
battu du coup Richard rapport avec les
dents les deux gains les deux gains sont
sont de très très haute factures
attention il y a pas le choix à ce
niveau là pour gagner une partie c'est
tellement dur que ça fait énorme partie
après il y a eu que des nuls mais que
des parties intéressantes
kymer aurait pu aurait pu l'emporter
très clairement aurait mérité peut-être
mieux
et on a eu aussi un autre pressing de
Daniel guéri contre
erwana
et alors de l'autre côté donc les
résultats sont pas encore tous rentrés
il y a beaucoup de zéro
mais on va sûrement avoir Luis soupie
qui va abattre
Erine Lamy et tabatabec qui joue encore
contredyban mais ça risque de faire nul
on va avoir deux parties de folie quand
même on peut les citer Thomas biersen
contre la jeune jeune sœur de Prague
Babou donc là c'était c'était vraiment
des parties
ouais c'était des parties monumentales
et Max vertaman qui qui a battu
ergos péchak et ça c'était quand même
des parties de incroyable que vous
pouvez regarder parce que ça allait très
très vite et c'était des parties
d'attaque assez incroyable c'est ça
du coup je peux vous montrer les
appareils de demain et vous voulez voir
donc demain on aura so Wesley contre
herigasi on aura 14 heures demain et 14h
pareil avec Kevin tous les deux
donc Wesley Ariane contre Prague qui est
mort contre karsen la quasi finale le
départage champion du monde de Blitz on
aura
dingly Rennes
contre
McDo slow on aura anus gris contre
goutiches
contre rapport donc avec bien sûr deux
joueurs on a un rapport et on a aussi
cookeh qui auront un coeur peut-être de
se refaire sur les joueurs locaux
pas si facile avec les pièces noires
avec les Blancs vous avez les Noirs le
lendemain et c'est pas
intéressant cette affiche bonne forest
rapport parce que les deux joueurs sont
des joueurs très créatifs qui aiment
beaucoup envoyer et du coup c'est une
partie qui peut être intéressante à
regarder
évidemment je guéris c'est un peu une
autre école c'est plus solide en fait
donc bien sûr pourquoi je peux gagner je
veux dire on va pas avoir là demain
avant de Forest rapport on peut très
très bien voir les deux rois des requis
au bout de 8 ou quoi tu vois ce que je
veux dire ça peut ça peut envoyer
qui affronte le champion du monde
et de belles parties en tout cas à
suivre donc donc
préparez les boissons préparer les
collations pour demain 14h parce que le
stream va être long le stream va être
long un peu comme aujourd'hui et puis
voilà donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi le
stream en votre compagnie merci d'être
actif sur le snap c'est cool c'est ça
donc on vous dit à demain même heure
tout pareil et puis et puis portez-vous
bien et et à très bientôt c'est une
bonne soirée bon samedi soir à vous
salut bye